Any other question or are you good?
>> Uh, I actually have another question,
but it's it's not about the Trinity. I
don't know if that's okay.
>> Well, let's see. I don't know. We'll
see. Let me take because the cat needs
to go. I don't Good. Yeah. So, what is
it?
>> Um, basically like, you know, like uh
you you talk about like the Islamic
dilemma and stuff.
>> Yes. Um, a thing that I've heard like
raised to sort of counter it is like
what why would Satan confirm the Bible?
Like do do you would you know how to
like explain?
>> That is a stupid That's response to it.
>> Sorry, what' you say?
>> That's their response. Why would Satan
confirm the Bible?
>> Yeah. Yeah, that's what I've heard.
Yeah,
>> that's what they told you or you're
coming up because you have a sick mind.
>> No, no, no. I've heard I've heard it.
I've heard it from them.
>> Oh, you thought about it because you're
a sick mind like that. Okay. So, how
would Satan convince Jews and Christians
to follow his prophet if he didn't agree
with the biblical prophets and then
confirm
who Jesus is and his mother is to the
extent in which he can then get them to
think that he is truly in line with them
and he's going to give you the correct
understanding interpretation of their
message. Because if I follow your logic,
when Paul says that the serpent appears,
Satan appears as angel light and he
raises up servants
to deceive you by presenting another
Jesus, a different spirit, different
gospel, then that means according to you
that makes no sense because Paul is
saying that's Satan's MMO. Satan will
send someone to talk about Jesus
in order to get you to think he does
believe in Jesus but then give you the
right understanding of who Jesus is.
That's actually his mastermind. Because
if I come and tell you Jesus is a fake
and his mother was a harlot, would you
even entertain anything I say?
>> No.
But if I tell you Mary's the greatest
woman that God created and sinless,
Jesus the Messiah, his word sent down a
mar and spirited from him who did
miracles and will return again. Will you
now listen to me?
>> Yeah,
>> you got it. In fact, that's the
deception. If you look around you, you
know how Muslims get Christians and
deceive them and dupe them? Can I tell
you how?
>> Sure. Yeah.
>> Interfaith dialogue.
What we have happening right now among
Protestants and Catholics, they have
what's called interfaith dialogue. Well,
they'll bring in rabbis or Muslims to
talk about the commonality. And then
you'll see when the Muslims talk about
the things they believe about Jesus and
Mary and common Christians, you'll see
the shock reaction of the Christians.
And I've seen it. I'm going to give you
a story. When I was leaving Illinois to
come to the state because of the corrupt
judge,
one of the last
events that I went to was an interfaith
dialogue at a Catholic church where
Catholic women's group meeting with
Muslim women
invited a Muslim man to give a
presentation on Islam about the
similarities between Catholicism and
Islam. And these women were shocked that
the Muslims hold Mary in such honor and
believe that she's born of a virgin and
he's a messiah. And not one of them
asked about, "All right, what about the
differences?
What don't you believe? And why are we
different if you're saying we have
that's how Satan deceives,
>> right?" Yeah.
>> So there you go. So Satan is smart. If
Satan comes and sends me someone said
Jesus is a fake, I'll say get the lie of
here. I'll give you an example. That
bastard that came earlier who said that
Yahweh of the Old Testament is not the
true God cuz he's a bastard, son of
Satan. You see how quick I sent him to
his mother, right?
>> Yeah.
>> So, you think Satan's going to get my
attention by telling me Yahweh the Old
Testament is Satan?
>> No. Yeah.
>> But what if someone tells me, "Hey, All
of the Quran is the God of Abraham. He's
the same God of the Bible." Oh, really?
You think?
Show me.
>> Yeah.
>> And they show me.
>> Wow. Really? You believe the same God I
do? You believe God sent Abraham, Isaac,
and Jacob and Moses and Jesus? WOW. SEE
THE DECEPTION that 2 Corinthians 11:es
104. Let me show it to you in verses 13
and 15. So, it's the contrary. Satan
knows that if he gives you straight up
poison, will you take it?
>> No.
>> And you know it's poison. Would you take
it?
>> No. Unless you're sick like Protestant
believer, right, my friend.
>> Yeah.
>> What if I bring you deep dish pizza and
chocolate cake and inside the pizza and
cake is poison that was like you dead,
but you don't see the poison because
it's covered by what your eyes like?
>> Yeah. Then will you more likely reach
out for pizza and chocolate cake if
you're not on a diet and try to lose
weight so you don't look like
constantly.
>> So that's what Satan does. He gives you
chocolate covered poison. Here it is. 2
Corinthians 11:4. Oh that you would bear
with me in a little folly. And indeed
you do bear with me for I am jealous for
you with godly jealousy. For I betroth
you to one husband that I may present
you as a chase virgin of Christ. Meaning
Christ is your spiritual husband. You
are a spiritual bride. So you have to be
a spiritual virgin because Christ
doesn't come and marry anyone
physically. So how do I stay a spiritual
virgin? How do I lose my spiritual
purity? But I fear lest somehow is a
serpent deceived by his craftiness so
your minds may be corrupted. Satan will
rob you of your spiritual virginity by
corrupting your mind and deceiving you
from following another Jesus
thinking it's really Jesus but now I've
been given the correct understanding of
who he is serpent deceive by so your
minds may be corrupt by simplicity that
is in Christ for he who comes preaches
another Jesus whom we have not preached
or if you received a different spirit
which we you have not receive or a
different gospel which you have not
accepted. You may well put up with it.
See that?
>> Yeah.
>> All right. Now, how does he then do
that? By sending false teachers.
How do I know? Let's read 2 Corinthians
11:13-15. For such are false apostles,
deceitful workers. They appear as if
they are servants of God, but they're
deceived by Satan to deceive you,
transforming themselves into apostles of
Christ. No wonder, you shouldn't be
shocked. For Satan himself transforms
himself into an angel of light.
Therefore, it is no great thing if his
ministers also transform themselves into
ministers of righteousness who end will
be according to their works. So, you got
the wrong mindset, which I thank God you
do because you don't think like Satan
because that would make you satanic. Did
that answer your question?
>> Yeah. Yeah, I did. Yeah.
>> You're a good man, brother. So, if
that's it, no trin question on Trinity,
we're moving on, mister.
>> Okay, sure. Thank Thanks for answering.
>> You're a good man, brother. English
Malaysian. Stay away from Malaysia and
stay faithful to Jesus.
>> Yeah,
>> you're a good man. God bless you,
brother.
>> Right,
>> man. I'm still I got like a lot of
energy in